it's totally fascinating people
buy such watches for thousands
sometimes tens of thousands of
euros it's just a piece of interchangeable
technology but it's
an awful lot brand is a feeling of luxury and how
you create it how you create these irrational
prices build up for decades that
explains the  head of just
iwc the christ granger mr. of
course also which superstars he is
collaborating with and how i
finally came up with an idea you can find out in the conversation
now
mr. chris hall philipp thank you for letting
me be there and welcome to
offside  in our podcast on what
we have of course only had since last
year, before that all
meeting rooms were here now we also have
an audio studio and i have to say it was
the first touchdown i had here
on the journey to you right at the
airport in  represent zurich how
warmly welcome at the airport what
is the exact name of the ball comes left he
had sma  rt tv called
exactly what you are doing, so to speak, already
consciously welcoming the people at the airport,
so you are already very good
here too, on your absolute I think we
are also one of the very few luxury
watch brands that have a real home
market in German-speaking Switzerland if  you
imagine in geneva or in the jura there
are of course hundreds of watch brands that have
been at home there for 100 years plus but
here in the german-speaking
eastern switzerland we are of course the largest
brand associated with this
region and so we
now have unique ones  heim
advantage because we are the only watch brand that
is the government from here you in
schaffhausen are now part of the
brand is already aware that
you also communicate a story about it
absolutely yes that is certainly
a
unique selling point in the industry
we have our very own
founding history we are also the
only swiss company  the brand was founded by an
american who was an
entrepreneur, watchmaker and engineer
florentine aristo jones who came
from boston at the age of 27 because he worked for the world
watch company at the time and
actually wanted to combine swiss
craftsmanship, which was absolutely top
at the time, with the efficiency of
american production methods
and then he came here 27 of
course didn't speak a word of german and then set up
the first centralized production in schaffhausen
and
actually brought technology and
craftsmanship together right from the start
and we still do that today that's why
we say we are the engineers of fine
watchmaking with us  technology and
craftsmanship are never a contradiction and always
in harmony and that is of course also
here in the vicinity of the
precision engineering industry
ux are at home but
here actually closer to the german
car brands to the precision mechanics
wear generic brands like abb georg fischer and
everyone else who is in schaffhausen
why is the whole topic of
watches such a swiss topic in
general i mean also your market companions
it is yes  all very many swiss
companies yes yes i think it
really comes from a swiss
mentality to drive things to perfection with a lot of patience and a
lot of
perseverance and strength
i think you
have to be a little bit focused
and introverted to convert more successfully
that is  something has to be a lot of patience
, we need an extremely steady
hand and i think that's a
bit in line with the swiss values that you d
n't give up, don't take shortcuts, but r
ally focus on the perfe
tion of craftsmanship, something that's const
ntly being improved over gener
tions and generations in very, very
uch  great continuity what has to be a  back
then it was probably the case
that there were networks like that, the
founder of you and I first had
employees then at some point became self-
employed then of course then it
also developed here in the area then it’s
the competence of the dwarfs in the western world
who make software  or for any
apps, it's probably been
around for 100 years now or we're talking about
exactly 1850, so in the order of
magnitude I was 10 68 exactly you know that I
wasn't even considered was officially
founded so it's been a
while but I think it's like that  the fact that
there are networks here too was kept
so that the wave figures above all
in the jura are very clear and that can of
course therefore that at the very beginning
were watchmaking everything was
done in homework they were often
farmers who used the winter
months  when there was a lot to do out in the field building
clocks by
candlelight and then of course there was
d  the whole movement through the reformation
already when this whole
art of watchmaking was really established in geneva and
then of course we see over time
that i then developed the entire industrial
base, all the
suppliers have developed and the
entire manufacturing competence has developed across all
areas of watchmaking
nevertheless we are a bit on
our own here in eastern
switzerland of course we don’t have the same basis i could
probably say where there are 720 watch companies
here within a 100 meter range
and we always had to expand
our own technicians
train our own
watchmakers we have from the start  our
own apprenticeship in fine
watchmaking here our own cnc technology how
many of the jobs we have here
at the location just over 750 and
worldwide it is over 1300 and how did you get
into the whole world so to speak
I mean we are about the same age
and
say  with a certain  how did you get into
this value a yes so with my father
was
excited for me gloves i
think maybe one first approached
this industry really came about the
time when i and my father my father
has a great affinity with switzerland
we always had holiday homes my
grandparents have  lived in
switzerland for a while and my father always
dreamed of this mechanical watch i
think my first memory is
when i was about four
years old i sat in a jeweler in bergen for what felt like six hours
and all the
watches were looked at then made up his
mind but made up his mind  probably
much shorter in reality but you can show
me and that was actually
always the approach where i thought one
day that's part of it you have to have a
sensible mechanical system i think
that was really the entry point for me
and i found myself very
early on
I was interested in design when I was young. I started very
passionately  to draw at home the
start also actually came with
sports shoes ski and snowboard something
tasks so in the late 80s it
really started with brands that l
hof freestyle that inspired me a
lot to design neon yellow roses and
stuff like that and then I got it through the
I always liked designing all sorts of
categories
and ended up in interior
design when I studied architecture.
I just studied architecture in
southern England and after that it was like that and it
was actually during the
internship year that his course on the
internet in England where I  the first
time return always worked in
london brought his and next to
some high street fashion stores that
designed again then came the first order
from a company that
specialized that was the
purveyor to the royal court for cufflinks and
men’s accessories and it was  a shop
project on long street and
i  ch actually discovered my love for this
luxury industry, above all,
for what was so beautiful Hartley
seemed, the watches and jewelry, because I
saw that the museum
quality of the exhibition
concept comes together with high demands, light and technology, expensive materials, beautiful architectural expression in the shopfitting  of course there were also high budgets and i
liked that and that's when i
actually thought about this shopfitting
and exhibition building that's the part that
interests me then i ended up working
in zurich for a year at the
interior design effekt and then
at some point our mother called
group direction whether we are interested in
a pitch number increase for a museum
at lc schaffhausen and that's why
all the alarm bells went off in me because
i was a big fan of iwc from my student days
and then i threw myself on
this project and had a boss
together at the time  nights on
my laptop  developed concepts
for pc in the basement museum and we won this
pitch and i can remember
exactly and when i walked through the door for the first time in 2005
i thought wow this
company i like endangering
the climate people like it more
and that has changed  to this day it hasn’t
changed and so i then started saying
museums designers got hold of it
then you will discover there he
has the sometimes man the power the
battery is empty he has a lot of passion and
then you would say about it pulled
by the company from the architect’s office,
so to speak  graduated myself - when i was
hanging at the time you can still see that
today a small boutique is attached to the museum
and that was in
2005 the time when iwc was thinking about building
up the first brand boutiques worldwide
and there were a lot of
projects and we have  that's why i was
in charge of the project in schaffhausen, but
saw that nobody worked at
ibc who dealt with shopfitting or architecture
knows and thought
that might be an
opportunity i applied there said you want a
lot of boutiques tree i can do that and
that's how it happened and we pay our i ask
a park is after that but you
're told in the preliminary talk it's
not that easy  if you do a bit of
research my feeling is we're talking
if it's in the order of half a billion
euros that's completely wrong
no comment
so I think I'll do what you
can find on the net at wikipedia and
that's how it's been over the years
now has a harder  phase i think because
of kona where there was initially loading to
elections of the chinese tourists who
also i think a lot of customers
were missing here in europe
has probably just gone down
now is high again no culture
we will have experienced the pandemic all
together i think we have
seen that the travel behavior
of mankind has changed enormously  of course we
have a big return on
the one hand to
local consumption, of course people
today buy much more where they are at
home than was the case before the pandemic
, because international
terrorism is of course still a long way
from where it used to be  you can see that
in all the studies and figures and
on the other hand we have of
course seen that there has been an
incredible
development spurt in the digitization of our
entire consumption i think this is
also significantly accelerated that today
the smartphone is of course this
main interface  between us and the
world around us, whether it's
entertainment and streaming, whether it's
music, whether it's working via
zoom and teams and skype and others, or
via the shopping mile, i
think social media brings it all
together a bit  and due to this
acceleration of the changed
living conditions from last year, the
natürl  I also gave consumer behavior an
incredible boost or
saw that, of course, people around the world
buy much more in digital channels
than in physical life
before and that, like me, has
accelerated this long-term trend again
also that a larger
proportion of should you sell through her
is clearly your own shops then
dealers very strong and
now has directly that is that
so that you could really live on it now
I alone we were
always very strong at the beginning  discussed
with all the people who asked
us came sell one online and
if you want to overtake it cost
from 5,600 euros up to
70,50,000 a wide range back then I think what
you asked this question has become
obsolete very quickly because we simply see
that is  today a question of a service
offer and is a question of the
multitude of  interaction and shopping
option we assume that often
by the time i a person has decided on a
mechanical watch, that can
sometimes mean maybe 16 17 18 points of
contact with the brand
that is quite a complex and
sometimes very long process and we may know
that  each of us ourselves that
we sometimes find brands likeable find
products interesting we
have always saved it like this
one day i will fulfill my
dream but it may take another
five years it will take eight years until
you really get to the point where
for some reason everything
comes together they say yes now i'll go for it
and we just see the same also
within the the shorter journey of
real product interest purchase
could go in all directions
maybe i'm in the mood to get
advice from the multi brand like teller
about  different marketing
have a great relationship with them
the salesperson hits
me in the end maybe i already
know exactly which brand i want to go to a
brand boutique maybe i just
saw the ones i would really like to have
then it wasn’t available somewhere at the moment i
wanted to buy it
i’ll take a look  quickly leyen cdu
it there and then does it at the gate at the
airport on the smartphone and i
think our task is simply
to offer the entire service portfolio and
to make it as easy and as pleasant as possible for our customers to interact with us
, of course we know  it is also
more lucrative for you to
sell directly than to go through the dealer
that is in the end it's typical the
chicks that everyone is talking about
when you say it's possible to
sell directly is of course much more
added value for you than elsewhere i
think you're just allowed  don't
underestimate how popularizing a
brand works overall yes we
can say today the main  the real
channel for the information is digital
is probably via social on the
other hand we can already see that
the human contact points are very
important that is the retailer where
something is presented in the window that is
someone across the street at the restaurant or
on vacation or doing sports  or she's
wearing a certain watch through st that
looks good that's maybe someone
on tv i admire or a
music star or someone else
my real world friends to say
where i've been looking on the
wrist say i identify with them
me what they wear what he wears
and i think these these points of
contact are very important
and i think it's risky to say
i focus on a single point of
contact and believe that
that's just enough i think
see what then snaps in front of the dealers
as  they noticed you sold is
also direct so that was so that you
then suddenly  since we got calls it has the
motto
we've bought products for millions of euros for years and
now they're selling without us that
probably didn't please everyone
well we can see the situation in
many cities today where we have very, very
fair partnerships with our
dealers  and
also operate with each other directly in the closest environment i believe
that i simply believe in the power
of the choice for customers i
believe there are different
customer profiles who
are looking for different shopping experiences
and will try to cover in advance
how many of their own countries do you have because the
built-in  so many own ibc is
now so if you ask how
many may talk mono brands
we have i built i think i
started with the serial number
0.05 that was zurich with 0 3 not being
finished that was geneva back then we are
probably  today at over
270 80 okay that's also a
large share of sales n  namely you now
have your own shops that's already playing
a role is
by the way in the the chick's playbook right
there so both
online trading and your own shops is,
so to speak, the typical element of
what you do cleverly yes I
think that you just we  we
simply have the task as a brand to present the
physical expression of our brand
that has to become
reality somewhere the dream has to become
reality somewhere i think i've noticed
that very often with brands that only
appear online and then also have a relatively
flat website from a  a certain
level of interaction with a brand
or a certain level of spending that you have
with a brand do you ever ask yourself
who is behind it here are the
founders what does it look like how does it
feel and of course more emotional
and also the high-priced the the purchases
the more you want to experience that, the more you want the
customer to experience it more than just want
the end product  test why
know the story you would like to meet
the nation he the designer all the people at some point
and also understand what
values this company embodies and i believe that it is really the task of the brand to really make that come true in our own appea
ance  customers have the opportunity to
really immerse themselves in this dream man to
really see who is behind it how are they doing
and there is of course the
ultimate experience in our industry
is always visiting the manufactory we
are one of the few companies and few
product categories in the world where you can
still come to schaffhausen  you
can really see from the
very first design sketches to the finished watch
step by step how such a
mechanical one is created because i have
many companies have to write down today
designed by xyz
manufactory in the samples samba
complete front we have the advantage
that it really has been everything since 1868  happened here in
one place and our kun  of
course you can also see it and that has
a power in charging the product
that of course goes further than just
advertising or
without looking for it when you run out of shops
so that means you always have top cities
probably or
what the city has to bring with you, what
then the location  so its the 1a were
exclusively or would you
say it somehow depends
on what you are trying to achieve
but basically we look very
closely where our weather traffic is coming from of
course we are constantly building up so
-called ones where they
can see the overlay and  to physical
distribution with our digital
traffic and from that we of course
like to take a great look at where new centers
are emerging we can see that at the moment we
have, for example, at the moment a large
concentration of new interest from
which states like texas at the moment
that another brand saudi arabia the
is eerily emerging and then
we'll see  of course ok where are the
customers where is the situation where is the
demographics at home which i would like to
speak in context you would mean usa so what
is what drives the text that right now
i believe that many people who are
in this segment are the monkeys for me
years ago many of them have found their
new home in texas or
have moved to texas in the last few years
and we are now seeing in
such cities as from the also
because of the industry base that is there
also because of the
so we have seen that too  a
few years ago, for example, in phoenix
arizona, many blue chip companies suddenly became
entrepreneurs because they
found their winter homes. as a
result, the scouts aim there was such
a concentration we see it similarly
at the moment in the east inside and
photos from back then and stuff like that  further and then
you need to learn the appropriate things and
if we see that it will naturally
grow there sooner or later
Of course, we also have a
physical presence
reference to api mio
everyone who hears us here regularly knows our colleagues
because we are also allowed to be
involved in the
company to a very, very small extent because at mr what the
colleagues from premium do is
real-time market research within
minutes you get representative
answers to your question so you
sit at the meeting and ask yourself is
the slogan understand that people is
the business model viable before that
people use it or somehow
tests it with api millions of very large
companies do it  already red bull vw
love beiersdorf and also the day on
youtube video if you want to try it out
, send a short mail to pr at from the
colon com and you
can start the first survey right
away a bit about your really
big partnerships we talk that
he already  if you deal
with deficits, lewis hamilton comes along very quickly, i.e.
me  think munich
airport you can't get to the
gate now without seeing
the ghs hamilton
positioning very centrally with you but also
tom brady we're showing the global icon we
're now a bit that's
really big names before classes have to
playbook has  it just came about because they
have always appreciated the brand authentically
whether they addressed how
does it work like that yes i think basically
it all goes back to the
philosophical consideration is of course
in the luxury sector the whole idea of an assoc
ation between characters and their
values and in the end one  the brand and
the customer has been at the center for hundreds of
years, well over 100 years
now, of course, it started very
originally, of
course, luxury products
were often identified with the nobility with
people at European courts in the
past and then craftsmen there,
too, the people  the then exclusive
saddles shoes clothes herge
that of course they became known about
what queens and kings and
princesses and princes wear psion z
and there really was
something back then I think 1700 or so there was
already the first european
gossip press imprint format the
latest trends could then be
exchanged  well that had been established for a relatively
long time then later came the world
of film and cinema which of course led to
huge changes because
then of course there was suddenly the one on the
water there as a real figure so what was
there as an actress as an actor had
the natural values  very early on
products wore
represented a certain style but
there are also virtual figures and there
is really the reference of the brands more
to the myth of the virtual i.e. the
character than that is really the
actors and actresses
necessarily behind it is so
therefore dignity as well as the  the mark of the
risen man still  bigger than
now only if this way only the
actor actor actor
and these these associations that i
have always felt important to fill products and
brands with an identity and with
values that are easy for our c
stomers to under
tand and that is why i think this is it
in the basta topic that has always been the
luxury industry, we see
again and again today that of course people are
already looking very closely at who
they identify with and which brands
and what type of products these
people also wear and then i think
from this point of view we have two
questions, the first  the question is who
represents the values of the brand authe
tically, so with us it is this,
this orientation, this balance of dr
ve and technical understanding and a
so a certain courage and then
e often have that on the water that they tell
story like that supplemented the local
we see that  tom brady in
american football the see  we at
lewis hamilton in formula 1 were
n't the obvious candidates
now as to become the codes in their
respective sport but of course they worked
hard and through great
determination and then of course
a bit of luck they made their
way and have been successful  done
and that is something that we see very close to
our brand and to the history of
our founder and of course
also through here against all odds
that has managed to
build up this company in switzerland and that is of
course an approach that these self-made
personal see this  we also
really consciously fire the other point
you just mentioned briefly is
then we always have an authentic
relationship it's real it's not
just
path but we really do have
an interest and we saw that with
people like tom brady die  have been
interested for years like ten or
even barry cooper who has been for years  previously
only supported where we then of
course always see that there is also a
natural affinity between the brand
and the topic of water then there is also
telling the story
that when it was i think it was
somehow an
mwp and an honor for sportsman of the
year  or something like that, so when he
comes on stage in civilian clothes, so to speak
, that he also consciously considers
which watch he would like to wear and of course there
is also someone, you see again and
again, who very consciously
makes stylistic decisions about who wears the watch
and makes them  Of course I am also
very happy to see that, for example,
doctors at the hillsborough aid
project report after the last
Super Bowl was he had the top ten chrome
os fc bayern a real
sports watch real american watch that also
tells so much about the spirit of
top gun this  work hard play hard and of
course that was after
winning the super bowl that fits like a
glove and then ha  did you see when he was in the
other last year visited president
biden with the team
he had communicated perpetual calendars in stainless steel
to me differently tk tour giant watch marc
rich content in there whole invention from
1985 but depends very much on the packaging
that was natural  perfect so if you
want that statesmanlike thing it was of
course the perfect watch and
so he always manages to find the
right iwc for the right occasion
and that's also
a lot of fun for me to watch if
someone really thinks it's a  good
feeling okay okay was you
then immediately notice what a sales figures
so if so how do you want to
appear in such at such
events it is our plan so that you are there also
feel that okay there another photo
went through the world and
zack people are buying
i think this functional principle
has been proven over the years that is also
the reason why i think they still
have something in mom  ent in the
streetwear area happens with a
collaboration and how important
the flag bearers of this
collapse are that it doesn't matter whether it
comes from cani or from whoever
in the situation clear if if this
principle didn't work
i think i would have noticed  it hasn't been done for centuries
but the fact that this was
already done in dortmund is of course
still an important
part yes but i think it's a pity
that these 18
contacts are then significantly shortened
that was the rental of the pons there, so to speak
So that's an exciting question
that I I ask myself that
again and maybe
your listeners also know that a bit
from their own buying behavior why
you often have brands and
products that you've been finding for quite a
while  she really
likes her a lot can identify with the brand
maybe you have that
product also already researched but for
some reason you have
n't bought it yet or not and at some point
it will happen and with me i'm a
relatively emotional buyer i'm
someone who uses the excel list costs
benefit analysis makes nice big man
seal weeks
reacts more quickly  emotional what is
buying privately and that's sometimes
i don't know exactly why is
it happening at the moment iks why are you suddenly looking at
something again and saxony
now is the moment that i think
it's so complex in this area of
er behavior that  is really difficult is
because you put your finger on it
why it was exactly this or
that moment but it always has
something to do with the fact that it is called back to
attention through
some contact there is definitely
but in the end it is  nevertheless also a
gut feeling that you say that or
you as a team ok with that we could bring the
brand forward  that's why
let's do formula 1 or to speak to me
probably a lot of
people look at you the other there
is something in golf right now and
so many things are happening worldwide in sport in a
wide variety of disciplines in
show business
so in the end you still have to
as  seo then also have a gut feeling
where fits right
now absolutely i think that
also describes our industry quite
well we have on the one hand you have
your data of
course didier insights are there you see many
things you can measure
today it can also do a lot more today  measure as was the
case a few years ago but
certain things in luxury you will
never be able to measure why a
product becomes a hit today only if you had done that
with crowdsourcing and opinion
polls most of today's highly successful luxury products will
probably never be on the market  came
but there is there is still
a moment the creations a  moment
of intuition and gut feeling, of
course, also from fans who
cannot be emptied in a sap process before
we believe that this
component that exists in our knowledge
is still
so speak now not just a
week after the weekend of  possible
brady resignation also promise on the
weekends after the australian open
victory of nadal so the tennis golf and he
wears that is now also known in
the other watch brand and since his model
costs several hundred thousand euros
that's so legendary these rap
songs are from  drake over over the
clock from the del so you look at then
plays [ __ ] very soon actually
need also because now a
competitor of you is
probably having a very good day thanks to
the success and the presence of nadal so
is that both long since warm he have
you  a bad day not at all what
i've ever what he's
my again with the emotional pro  first and foremost i
am thankful every day that our
products continue
to be popular in our industry that's really
for me that's actually that he's also
looking at the last with the
digitization of the quartz and
started  in the crisis of the 70s
80s to the smart watch to
consumer behavior today and everything we are
now experiencing with the messiah the
fact that mechanical watchmaking
is so popular that’s
great that’s not something to be taken for
granted and i think every
time you come back  seeing that this is
still such a category i
am first and foremost grateful and then of
course also the possibility that this is
one of the few differentiating
products on the body especially of
men who you can really recognize
and celebrate like a
mechanical man  specifically it doesn't matter
whether it's a racing suit or whether it
's a tennis outfit or  he whether that is
the golf clothing such a watch is of
course one of the
elements that you really have to make a
statement let's say which
ones in the package alone the fact that calwer said
about smart watch i mean
the apple watch is also
in this one  at the moment also somehow
people with a high household
income who are thinking about such watches therefore very strongly also felt it cost you a lot or do you see that in the overall rating, so to speak, that luxury watches
have suffered a lot since the smart watch
, which is why the apples are falling  watch outside
is also the opposite that
is yes i think it just suits us
that our disruption as an
industry they came with the quartz watch in
the 70s because that was the moment
when you
precisely go further back into the
age of pocket watches etc  the
only way i as a human
could carry precise time with me on the go
without au  looking at the church tower is
that i had a pocket watch or later
a wristwatch with
me whose task was first and foremost to tell
me the time they were of
course already a piece of jewelry back then
there was gold and the caps
were already highly decorated but  that was
an essential product to know
what time it is then the quartz watch came
and the quartz watch naturally brought much
higher precision for a fraction of the
purchase price and of course when the
mass imports started it was completely
unclear how the mechanical
industry would continue  luckily,
this development then
led to the countertrend, which of course started with klaus
and the perpetual calendar in 1985, which then
again set a deliberately complicated
mechanical watch as a countertrend
to the cheap quartz flood and
then of course the swatch, which of
course tried  did the swiss
industry back then to
rev  elution over a watch
that then made a completely different statement
than the mechanical movement and from
that point of view the mechanical
watch actually
developed in parallel as a piece of jewelery as a
luxury object and as an emotional product
that was basically
a very  good prerequisites for the
task of the smart watch is where
it quickly became apparent
that one is an electronic device
that is a
functional electronic device that is
not and decorative objects that is not
a luxury object with which I can manage my
health function my calendar my
first  mozart and new
location but that is not a product with
which i can make a differentiating statement
about malawi, about what
i would like to say in life and so
on and this duality
actually had the opposite effect,
which of course also caused many younger people
people like that at all
we came up with the idea of putting something on the wrist
and i think that on the w
ole it actua
ly helped the mechanical industry, becau
e it also made this idea i have something on my wrist
clear and firmly estab
ished, even with the very young targe
group
to think about after your
job how can i differentiate with my
brand so iwc and you
differentiated through the story the story
but especially with certain brands is
similar so high engineering achievements
origin in europe often in switzerland
that means people already have a
big one  relevance in the history of differentiation
are you also looking at
upcoming sports shops right now up to the
partly on the go googles what
instagram looks at above and says okay
there are people who can fit in with us
so easy to win such athletes
who are so big such so
how power  he that and how
we look before that no of course of course
i think we
keep looking for similar things or we look
in each area to see if we can find people with
great potential with great drive who
embody our values who are c
nfident on the one hand but can also be do
e differently and responsibly it's
lso the case with brands with diffe
ent  characters are consciously looking for
very different types
and characters from taste then that is
relatively specific to us with
our brand but if i now
look at your partnership like a guru
who as a freeskier is just
18 years now for the chinese team
building 22  at the winter games
starts in slopestyle and halfpipe, etc.
we really have someone who represents exactly
these values from a compl
tely different generation is 18 and is no
starting to study in stanford only has t
is sport career ahead
of him and is really someone who is in
I think this boy is really
fascinating and very inspiring  d
that means you are a woman what percentage
and it is of great importance to you that the
women’s segment is generally
growing steadily i think you can
differentiate a bit at the moment that
is of course very strong and is also
driven by a very strong and
growing market in china but we
the rest of the world also sees that this is a
constantly growing group of
customers who like the
mechanical things from iwc let's say
a few words about china because that's
always something garage that
you talk about when you generally deal with luxury companies
, including all of them
all those listed on the stock exchange expect the big growth in
china so that further the luxury
boom apparently doesn’t just have to
come from china for you it’s
probably the same for you either way i
’ve failed china is a big
market in china is simply a market
of course due to the number of people
in china and the number of people who live
there their w
ohlstand are increasing, and of
course they are also looking for luxury. Of course, the numbers
alone are
a very relevant market.
I think they did it
well in that
we invested in China very early on
. We built brand awareness in China very early on.
We are delighted  today of course about the fact that
we can be very active in the market
and that the chinese
customers are of course also happy about the
vision and what they invest you
then open shops there where you can also find
testimonials that made me feel like that yes  well that
's not fundamentally different hand
caritas so where are we from the
outset i think we put a
lot of
emphasis on expressing the brand very strongly both through
our distribution and through our
partnerships in addition to the early phase
we have built up a network of
boutiques in china  and of course
also with pasta des and partnership  t
worked together who were relevant in the chinese
market and have built it up
step by step over the last
few years and
the next topic next to china the
next big market that works a bit
yes and don’t know what
I would have said differently
I really wanted afternoon
ask something because you have that in a snake
sport there is also
the hope you see big companies
buying there then your own nft companies on technology companies condition
i do
all that makes it bad wise
found the rents are in
competition again  on the level
of real meditation he thought there would be
a bargain somewhere it was nothing
but why are you looking there at all said
that
i mean that is exactly the
point we are going to address
earlier that of course the behavior
when the behavior of our customers
customer changes, we are of course the
first to react and this
wandlu
as with many trends that are
developing, time will show how
wipro fund and sustainable the trend
change really is and that we are
has behavioral changes but of
course we take this very seriously
and treat it is at the forefront in the
context of digital  transformation that
is very clear what calms me down again and also makes me
optimistic is the fact
that you can see something in him too with all the
approaches this is already there that
the luxury needs and behavior of
customers would
not be there either  looks different than at the
time of reunification is also there it's
about still exhibiting the mfps to flex
it goes up
the have to wear his objects and brands
avatar but it means
austrian different worlds
through so there are more
different yes but  I don't know at all, in
the end, what
exactly is different for me  ste
gaming platform or worlds and then
now your own worlds and argumentation
about everything that goes with it but it
says you look at everything now does
he go in himself do you look at the avatars
and says okay I want to be there
I didn't have to be there  we now
somehow have a watch lounge and so on
prince pi yes it's natural
everything is perfect here in the pioneering days that's
clear there's just you can't do the
final market research find the
perfect answer by then
the train has long left the station we know that
Even at the beginning of social media, it
wasn't really clear in which
channels would really prevail and establish themselves in the end
, and
at the same time at the beginning of the first web
expansion bonanza, it wasn't
completely clear how this and that will become
ecommerce with us or  whether it will be a
digitized meat product catalog this time, i
think we're going to start with
a little bit of finding
ph today  ase and so it's
no different here and i think that
over the next month ten years
we will see exactly how
luxury brands interact with our
customers in whether and how they certainly express it something
in the digital channels i
would have said now  somehow
instagram has asserted itself strongly and
for you yes that's my feeling too
i think it's really in the area of
nal and luxury brands and generally in th
rating area it's
till established as the number one r
ference platform in the west in the w
stern world  as well as that
probably did for the chinese market
but with us in the west it
is undeniably in the
program what it is exciting
because you can
see again that you use some classic advertising
locations i.e. posters times
square  he goes to certain offline places
and my suspicion is you
do it offline and then egg
to have feedback at least
partially yes i think that is
true above all for creative
out of home advertising that of
course it has changed a lot because
you have to be creative about these out of home
advertising formats
you could actually only do two kinds  either think about
what I said okay i want to
reach as many people as possible who are
walking by and would like to
generate as many word of mouth as possible afterwards
and maybe a little pr article if things are
going well and then at some point
they have google or maybe the ones who had
it on tuesday I had it  the
possibility to search the internet and
post in forums to publicize it a bit
and that is of course what
instagram absolutely delivers today that of course
these things are photographed and
simply reach a much larger
target group on the net it would
ever be physically possible and i
think it is  of course, a
huge changes that are ü  via
esther’s path, she has
developed what was previously not possible.
other offline things we
really do for the offline experience and
i think you can see how
digital and offline now work
together that the more
communication there is in the diet
hall  the greater the
need for such a brand and to express the relationship
with our customers in a really
representative physical way via
flagship stores via pop-ups via
roadshows via events
and that is becoming more and more
important the more digitization
is gaining ground it is really an
absolutely parallel  movement
like you can experience today in supermarkets and so
on you just notice
that this this anchor and this
pillar in the in the physical world
is an incredibly important component
of sa digital shaking
very fresh new here in the
podcast conversion make  a ii a software
the bridge description  stexts are
automatically generated, especially in
ecommerce, so incredibly important,
different, great, sold, also
really well marked, especially with a
view to seo, it has to work,
then with a view to the user
conversion, pöttmes also work here
, you enter a few
keywords automatically and a software spits them out
texts from as if i could
scale extremely well you can sell a lot in
your shop so dealers should
definitely
know conversion maker colleagues increase your
conversions increase euro sales
only need five keywords
say product also there is
a 14 for all listeners to the podcast  day
free
test phase for the product conversion
maker points
which is also interesting you are already making
offline now not only posters of the
classic kind but you
can also see the ski areas that then
gondolas so the underbody of a
thorough not followed on
instagram so to speak  n with one of the
big palais thurn in the loser is then
completely varnished or painted
and then these huge clocks, so to speak,
but the ski area is already so
ideas where I think it has both so
it somehow has these offline yes
effects but that is yes  people too and
with their skis and look up and take
pictures of exactly what
's in it that's like I said the
strength that people also hate with such actions today
i thought the basic approach is
always i want to build brand presence
where our type of customers
spend their time
spend your free time and spend your beautiful moments
there creating a connection that's
why I thought we already had a
partnership with jackson hole in
wyoming i always consciously look for
things like this now, for
example ski areas that people
really visit because of the sport
also go there maybe
i'll do tell me what we're doing at the moment this
year films laa  x we had previously been in
jackson hole wyoming these are always
areas that are really visited by
people who are looking for sport and are
searched for by people who really
want to go skiing it's not just about
the hut life but also about
the up and down here  the piste that
for us i just think it's always a
better master more our
target customers are on the road and that's why
you say more correctly
about this campaign on the one hand it
naturally has a radiance on the one hand our
customers will be there at the weekend and the
ski holidays will then really be over  driving
on the other hand and of course also
the radiance of social media and the
party when at times square there is
actually no other way to
argue than about instruments such
huge wastage i mean the
people walking around time square they probably
had to a very small extent
the wcm target group but
the feedback is so strong then it
seems  but we
make sense is doing that yes on the
one hand and i think it's
just a good thing that you certain
i always call that a bit of
flagship visibility is
just part of the playbook of a
luxury brand no matter if it's in a new
york  times or financed time is the
full page ad is or whether that's
just piccadilly circus total skl those
are just positions that's
simply part of the arsenal of a large,
globally significant brand
and that's what I think has
n't changed in the last few years either
not lost strength and that
's just a component of that of
the fan that we're opening it
up again isn't it sometimes difficult for you
to achieve success in this world because
quantitative success is very
short-lived you could probably take a
few years from  some ears
sell a lot but that doesn't make any
sense he has to have a certain one  they are
making shortages, so the borg watch market
is also the case in individual areas,
so it even comes out with a watch that
is even worth more than
the amount for which it is sold or
sometimes even worth more a few years later
, so you achieve
such an increase in value  even if you
somehow keep a product scarce how
do you deal with this
scarcity and what are somehow
to be kept very selectively and at the same time the
group has the desire to achieve as much sales
as possible logically
in every group i think
we just have to  who simply keep in mind the basic principles of the
luxury industry of
course what customers buy is
exclusive design to be unique
quality large finishing high precision
and in the end of course also a value
preserved a truth a certain
luxury i can function if
it is democratically the same everywhere that
is luxury  has then done that is of
course egg  an important component and
i think what we see as a
brand is that over time
we build a brand with a high brand strength and a high brand value that
customers
can identify with for generations that we do
all this for us it's not about
short-lived trends  and hypes and taking everything
with you for things that
nobody wants to see anymore two months later it's
not we don't live quarter to quarter
we've been living here for over 150 years with
products that are just as beautiful today
as they were in 1939 and which we hope will be
just as beautiful in 2300  are here
today and i believe this timeless
beauty is what just
differentiates luxury from other types of
trends that are just short lived that are
interchangeable that ultimately end up being
discarded and thrown away i
mean we have today we have watches
with us from 1868 1870 to today  be
serviced while still in new
condition and restored by our
watchmakers a  only be
brought to a high-quality condition and these are watches that
have dials that are as beautiful
as what you see today where people
say wow the eu could have been from two
years ago and that is
ultimately a sign of luxury and
sustainability when i  you have things that
last forever where the
only input is human creativity,
craftsmanship and the elevator, the
elevator force
goes into my wrists or my fingers and i can enjoy
it for generations and
that's clear, but nevertheless it probably feels like a
discussion that people
tell me you have a model that is
running well does he find
more then meet the annual goal
even better or more than meet that
so it's constantly this this
challenge is to stop
selling even more to produce
even more even though you knew it  sells that
is then probably call because you
dilemma by doing s  managing teckst has to be
more than other industries in the
beverage sector it won't be like that i
described the balance of supply
and demand that has been a key part of
our industry for hundreds of
years
how big is the smallest so if you are
lounge says something new sometimes  is it
then only for so my feeling was
for 10 15 o'clock in so more there is
n't such a product yet so that can
also be the case with yes there is
a up to a single piece of course
if you see the black one for example
ceramics the itanium perpetual calendar with
the white numbers that
lewis hamilton wore a season ago that was a one
-off for him that there is of
course there are other one
-offs and there are also very
small series and we have a
wide range and ok that  means if someone
comes along and isn't just a celebrity collector,
then they say i'd
like these courses and made like this to
decrease in
volume  n or the amount will you say
ok then let's talk about whether
we can only build a few for
you and you can see from our history that you
keep plugging in ok ok
everything how many of the people who
only buy from you carry or
then have several  watches so it's the typical
iwc buyer it's probably
not the only watch yes that's
interesting because there are i
look at them again and again but there
really are both there are definitely there are
also customers who buy their whole
lives  long exactly one single luxury that also
exists but of
course the proportion of customers has
grown over time who certainly
buy more than one watch over the years from one brand over several brands
i
think you can see that as with many
another passion for collecting that of course
if at some point the interest in a
product of a product category is big
enough then sooner or later
you want to  not just have one, of course
, but maybe two or
three more and depending on how people
approach their passion for collecting,
we also see that
some of the larger shipments prove it is conceivable for you
to
include the brand iwc
in a wide variety of cooperations beyond watches
you can see that there is now
a menu with porsche or ferrari
there is somehow not
just an author but there are also some
watches one or the other product
you think but
i think there is a bit of a
difference between what i generally think of
as
merchandising  would describe it as you see
it with the car brands, of course
, and what is then really here is
portfolio expansion i think
nowadays people come
to make it very specific for the core product
that is that is incredibly important i
think that this this era of wild
diversification i see that  today
not so strong I think the m  people
know if you want a good shoe
where you are going and have a very good
pen i now jochen that
prevents you need coat against you will
third life and for a top end
binoculars can see all the goods these are
that is that i think who i think
to the specialization of us as a
manufacturer of mechanical watches
absolutely beyond that is of
course that is because there are accessories and that is
that was there is that is clear that is
not always the case in our
industry but I wouldn’t call that
diversification  from portfolio
describe ok and with a view to the
now new generation so there is
now somehow a recent
conversation in a luxury watch influenza
and you get the feeling of because the luxury
buyer is getting younger actually so
you don't just have to take
metal purses and  china and the new
region but
suddenly it's the same with a target group of 16 to 17
year olds
yes it has always been the case that of
course the range of
age groups
differs a little regionally and that we have of
course always had very young
customers, the affinity and
awareness for brands will be the greatest
in the younger generation i think if
i now  my kids
might be observing, but i would
n't treat that as a scientific opinion right now
, but of course you can already see it
a bit that due to the
influence of brands in pop culture, of
course, awareness of brands
starts relatively early, so of
course that's already that today  certain brands are already slowly becoming known
in the age group of 19 years
old and of
course you have to make sure that you
don't miss out on that a reason if you
build up for for for a brand i
thought that back then you were still in
english elementary school i thought that
they  I am very impressed that
such a factor has made al
similar to what you saw with us,
that you can visit the iwc and they
then looked at the production of certain
consumer products, that is of
course clever if you visit
a certain brand of bread as a five-year-old
, I can figure out
what these young people do  then
do when seven hours of dorm at
18 or 19 go to buy bread for the first time
that might work
insofar as i think we have to
see on the one hand that
brand awareness is
built up early on and that we then of
course don't miss the moment of contact
and i will  now, for
example, in the next few weeks
, the lego speed champions will come out again
from the amg projectors and that will
keep the vehicle pointless in the formula 1 car
from last season, and
if the packaging is already big on the
front wing of the iwc brand,
then of course we hope  already from the
fact that this also applies to the 4+ target group, of
course  h a reason triggers awareness of
our logo and people
get in i can well remember which
brands were on my toys back
then it was all six years old
that just wasn’t compliant anymore by
today’s standards and that was
all open are john  player is
seeing toys but that was that i can
remember exactly which
brands i didn't come into contact with
because they just appeared on a
toy or in
picture books somewhere else i think
that's important for the things i've dealt with  a
floor plan and then, of course, as
you say, at the moment of addressing 16 17
18 where you start to
watch fan groups via social media and finally you have to
establish a bit of contact and depending
on
your age then, of course, then of course there is the purchase, older then and
then  Of course you want
people to have this in their heads now, but do you notice
that buying is old in the last few years?  years
younger so i
recently had a discussion with david fischer from means,
who says that this
whole thing is growing together more and more,
like luxury products and streetwear, for
example, it is no longer
allotted suddenly streetwear is also
luxury and vice versa and  there are
brands of clothing there are shops in
the most expensive locations the clothes are
really expensive but there are 16 to 17
year olds in the shop and we buy them that we've
always worn and then they
don't
even want to spend their income on a real car roof
fuel bills they say
young people today we just have
different
ways of spending their money more money falls too you notice what i
think is clear today that you are ready
or that people are
maybe ready to spend
astronomical sums for a pair of
sneakers even at a younger age in comparison  about the
product, yes, that will probably change,
but at some point you will also have  h
always an absolute price level, which you
also had to earn first and i
think that always takes a bit of
time and that we don't
see today that the boss buyers from
15-16 are all multi-millionaires i think that
's the development i haven't
noticed yet  how important is
music music is an area that is important
is important will be so far we haven't
had a huge mainstay in music
but all of that can still become
sport is the first priority for you
sport comes first and then comes
is actually
years of aviation and racing  that's
how it starts then i would say sport yes
we have that covered from the
athletes of course to our lau we are
one of the main sponsors of laureus
sport for good all the work
of laureus on
sport the life of young people in
all continents for  to
change better that sport this activity
put me in our brand and of
course music is also something  feedback and
creativity the incompetence brand
portfolio fits absolutely
okay okay okay works wonderfully have
christa then i think we've talked
through most of it now we'll see each
other more often talk in the
coming months and years and for us of
course the really big goal is that
you do too  since in may that when
we can hopefully start again
here we are all working on it and i would
say the probability is
very high then we will see each other live here
then hopefully a lot of
listeners will also experience iwc in life live in full
size and in color absolutely  all right,
our always core partner selection
antik sex helps you to choose the right
tools from the right platforms
with which you should work
if you work e.g. ecommerce your own
shop just has the choice between
very different shop systems payment system
many many other
tools  you need and still don't
know exactly what neh  me i now best
all sound kinda similar
the whole thing they call the convergence
evolution in e-commerce everything sounds so
honest you still have to of course get in
touch decisive for a
partner and choose the right one
that delivers exactly because xx
you say yourself  and out of 60, 75
percent know the platform from their own
implementation projects over 700
highly motivated consultants at wörth x6 m 32
locations in germany so whoever
is looking for software consulting wants to
know which platform really delivers what and not just the promise of the
work and checking under vallant me and my
wife  valente
point might be the right one
this podcast is produced by
popstars
at mr